[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je n'avais jamais utter mon
chapeau devant
personne maintenant je rampe et je fait
le beau quand elle me sonne j'étais
chien méchant elle me fait manger dans
sa
menote j'avais des dents de Lou je les
échanger pour des
queenorotes je me suis fait tout petit
devant une poupée qui ferme les yeux
quand on l'AC
couche je me suis fait tout petit devant
une poupée qui fait maman quand on la
[Musique]
tououche l'était dur à cuire elle m'a
converti la fine mouche et je suis tombé
tout chaud tout
reti contre sa bouche qui a des dents de
lait quand elle
sourit quand elle chante et des dents de
loup quand elle est
furie qu'elle est
méchante je me suis fait tout petit
devant une poupée qui ferme les yeux
quand on la
couche je me suis qui fait tout petit
devant une poupée qui fait maman quand
on la
[Musique]
touche je subis sa loi je file tout doux
sous son
empire bien qu'elle soit jalouse au-delà
de tout et même
pire une jolie pervanche qui m'avait
paru plus jolie
quelle une jolie pervanche un jour en
mouru à cou d'on
brê je me suis fait tout petit devant
une poupée qui ferme les yeux quand on
la
couche je me suis fait tout petit devant
une poupée qui fait maman quand on l'a
toutouche tous les sonambulle tout les M
mon dis en
malice quand ces bras en courage je
subirai mon dernier
supplice il anné de pire il anné de
meilleur mais à tout prendre qu'on se
pend iici qu'on se
pendailleurs s'il faut se
pendre je me suis fait tout petit devant
une poupée qui ferme les yeux quand on
l'accouche je me suis fait tout petit
devant une poupée qui fait maman quand
on la
[Musique]
tououche ch